ironically the Super Bowl ad is my
favorite piece of advertising in the
world the problem with Super Bowl it's
the creative that's filling it is
self-serving to agencies as a showcase
to win Awards and get more clients I
want everybody to hear something that is
incredibly important to what we're
talking about this is you Market every
day to direct consumer segmentations
that are very very narrow when you
create 50 consumer segmentations those
segmentations act like an accordion so
every day if we have validation that one
is good or bad we are adding or
eliminating consumer segmentations and
you are then doing bigger pieces of
content that I believe you will run on
streaming services as commercials you
look at your nine different commercials
then we sit in this boardroom in
September because we know Super Bowl is
the most underpriced and we look at the
nine videos and we say should we double
down on one place or is there a thematic
of these three you your Super Bowl spot
is the output of a year of very perfect
consumer work not the starting point of
a brand campaign for audacious
executives